the mainstream asian american narrative
has nothing to do with the vast majority
of asian americans in this country right
and that
the vast majority of asian americans in
this country don't even know what the
term asian american means right like and
that includes people like my parents
like i don't think my parents have ever
used the term asian american they refer
to themselves as korean sometimes they
refer to themselves as american
i don't think they've ever said they're
korean-american
and nor an asian-american is some
just weird concept to them and so it's
an interesting book in that it is a book
that i think argues
quite forcefully i hope against like
this type of like uh kind of i don't
know how to put it but like progressive
identity politics right like where i
think like none of it is really true
at the same time while trying to
understand what asianness means
[Music]
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast someone i've admired from afar
for a long time since his grant land
days
author
journalist his newest book is the
loneliest americans jay caspian kang
welcome jay
thank you that's like i think that's the
most enthusiastic introduction i've ever
had in my life that's what thank you
that's what we're all about here
setting new new heights high water marks
for enthusiasm but i
did become a fan of yours during the
grant land days and when grant land shut
down i was heartbroken i was like this
should have better come back
then it came back but i don't think you
were part of the comeback right it got
you kind of turned into the ringer and
you weren't there is that all right
yeah i left like uh even before
the sort of you know tragic end of
grantland i think i had been gone for a
couple years by then
but i was definitely the i imagine that
you were that what you read was some of
the stuff about jeremy lin yes
i like unless you're unless you're a
really big fan of like nba betting or
something like that it was probably
jeremy lynn stuff but yeah i was there
through linsanity and
um
i don't know it was cool like uh you
know bill bill simmons who was a guy you
know the person who was running the site
gave us a lot of freedom and
uh i don't know and wanted us to
write about things that we
were excited by and so
i don't know who wasn't excited by
insanity i think back on it and like
were those the best two weeks of my life
those are the best two weeks of
a lot of our lives
you know it wasn't like three sports
illustrated covers in a row like the
whole thing was madness
yeah yeah i went to the um i went to the
game in the garden like uh
they were nice enough to fly me out from
la to new york and it was when he was
going up against uh kobe yeah toby
yeah and he scored like 38 points
against kobe
and i was like about to cry in the
middle of the game you know i was like
what is wrong with me you know how many
of these basketball games have been
sitting here like trying to hold back
tears i was like i couldn't understand
it but yeah it was a full emotional
experience it was my dream to be the
back up point guard for the new york
knicks growing up
and even in my fantasies i couldn't
force myself to make it starter
it was like
hey look that's that uh you know that's
that internalized right oppression
it's like i can't be the starter but
maybe i could be the backup
you and fouchy must have had the same
well i mean i'm sure a lot of us
had that dream but the jeremy out did
my dream and
uh took the city by storm and he
actually that led to my breakup with the
new york knicks jay i don't know if you
know this about me but i i grew up in
this area from new york city fan and
then after
uh we
dumped jeremy linda essentially or you
know let him go to the rockets
uh i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i just
can't handle this anymore like
it was
like like losing
our golden child over money of all
things i mean if the knicks did one
thing right in their
uh history it's just [ __ ] spend money
on losers you know
like like jerob james got a fat contract
like anyone got a fat contract from the
team and then the guy who we all loved
uh who revived the season and made you
know like made my wife like you know
excited about basketball for the first
time in our lives like we let him go i
was like i just can't handle this
anymore
yeah it was like over
like 14 million dollars or something
like that and yeah i remember being mad
too because it's like
like even if you're not doing it from a
basketball standpoint you guys are
terrible you know so like what's the
basketball standpoint at least have
somebody in here who will draw fans in
and make them excited and you know and
even if he's bad at least it'll make
them think about the team you know but
um
i don't know james dolan is james he's
the worst is the worst and you know it
was hard for me to
like mellow after that um you know a lot
of jeremy lin fans turned on carmelo
because he kind of was running the team
at the time
uh
so i feel like you were part of history
you were the most prominent sports
journalist documenting the insanity and
i have to ask how the heck you got
started as a writer in large part
because i'm going to confess
i think you and i have a bunch of things
in common but when i was a kid i thought
i might want to be a writer or i did
want to be a writer
i showed up to college and i studied
english for one semester and [ __ ]
hated it it was like you know we read
mole flanders or some [ __ ] i was like
this is the worst thing ever
[Laughter]
like drifted off immediately it was like
all right i guess i'll
you know take an economics course and
the rest of it and and then i went to
law school
where everyone there
actually was someone who wanted to be a
writer at some point and had uh you know
didn't have the guts to pursue it for
the most part and they just went to law
school and you know because it seemed
more practical
um so so that that was a bit of my arc
and so like i admire the heck out of
people that actually managed to make a
career out of something that so many
people think about particularly if
you're asian because we have all these
pressures to do something eminently
practical right uh well you know i think
it's a strange story in that you know i
think my mother
uh
i don't know what you know i've talked
to her about it but i she always wanted
to be a writer but she immigrated to the
united states when she was you know in
her 20s and so it's hard to become a
uh writer when you're um
you know you're in a country that you're
not speaking your native language
anymore and so um
she did a lot of she sort of i think
placed a lot of that stuff on me and my
sister when we were little kids and you
know it's almost like a tiger mom thing
where she would
make us write a page a day every single
day i think starting when we're like
four and a half or five years old i
still have all these books and she would
like give us these notebooks and we'd
have to write and read every single day
and i think that basically went until i
was 16 years old and so
i don't know i had sort of this tiger
mom training on how to be a fighter and
i will just say that all that practice
sort of made things easier but um
yeah that's sort of where it got started
and i don't know i think luckily i i
really liked it you know if i had
resisted it i think i wouldn't have i
wouldn't have done it as a career but i
think the start of it isn't that good i
just did the math man if you wrote a
page a day uh for 12 years i mean you're
like you know four or five thousand
pages of i'm sure utter nonsense
yeah i go back
it's it's ridiculous it's like so the
only you know it's like oh we had this
for dinner you know and
this happened at school and it's just
like totally dispassionate except the
days when i like would have a little
league game or something like that and
then i would fill up like several pages
with explanations i would make box
scores and stuff like that but um but
yeah most of it is just nonsense right
like it's just like
uh i played with so rob you know and rob
and i played nintendo and then his mom
told us to stop and then i came home at
a dinner
and just strung out over
so
you get into journalism uh
grant land new york times you wind up
doing
a beat for
vice around
civil rights protest police brutality
specifically
right uh i mean what that was like a
pretty big transition i remember in your
book you talk about how
uh you were making a transition to video
or tv
and they were like don't worry it's just
like writing uh just be a more animated
version of yourself
[Laughter]
yeah
that was weird i mean
yeah i i went i mean i was did sort of i
spent my 20s basically not publishing
anything i wanted to be a novelist and
things were really not working out so i
mostly
played poker and surfed and
taught english in high school for like
eight years just getting rejection after
rejection
and then you know a lot of stuff
happened at once i got very lucky and
then i ended up at grayland
but um
yeah the television part of it was after
i had sort of been like i don't know if
i want to really write anymore and i did
a little bit of work in advertising and
then
someone was starting a show on hbo you
know a vice show on hbo about the news
and they asked me if i wanted to
audition for being like a television
correspondent and i was like
i was like are you sure it really
doesn't make any sense
someone who could be on television
just like
like mostly like you know like lie down
and you know type and type into my phone
i was like i'm not like an animated
person you know but um
they seem pretty committed and they seem
pretty convinced that i would be good at
it now i i think that they were wrong
you know like i think i was writing
about it but you know i don't know i
really liked sort of being a tv
correspondent just because the
the days were uh interesting right like
you're working on a team i mean you've
done some of this before right like but
like for us it was just like we would
we would fly to like st louis or we
would fly to
we'd fly to minneapolis or we'd fly like
grand rapids michigan or something like
that we'd stay in like you know like a
double tree and then we would it felt
like i was part of a team which was much
less sort of isolating than being a
writer and i enjoyed that part of it
like i loved working with my colleagues
and stuff i just didn't really like
being on camera well this made it into
your book and again it's an
extraordinary book the loneliest
americans this is what it looks like but
but i was fascinated by your description
of what it's like to report
on the protests that followed for
example
uh
shooting of a black person in one of
these communities and so you would show
up
uh and it did sound very very
um action-packed certainly i'm sure
there was like a lot of teamwork
involved because you'd be with a camera
person and a producer
you
experienced getting tear gassed multiple
times
and one of the things that you say in
your book that really
it
captured me was you talk about there's
like a pattern to the way that you would
cover these stories
where you would have a quote from a law
enforcement figure or some kind of
official a quote from an activist
and then ideally a quote from
the victim's family uh and that your
assignment in many cases was to try and
track these people down as quickly as
possible
right right i mean you know it's part of
the sort of unsavory part about being a
reporter right which is that sometimes
you have to talk to people who don't
want to talk to you sometimes you have
to sort of parse through things that are
being said to you that you know are lies
right um and sometimes you have to
uh you know deal with people who have
just under
gone through the worst tragedy sort of
unthinkable tragedy
uh that that you can't even really
conceptualize right in your head um you
know and so
uh
and yet like it's so rote like you have
to do those steps or else you're not
doing your job i actually think those
steps are good like that's what
reporters should do that's what the
public deserves to know
and so um
you try and fine-tune that a bit right
like you try and figure out what
strategies work i don't know how many of
these things i i think i probably
between you know writing for the new
york times and and then this job at
feis
i don't know maybe i went to 50 um
separate protests maybe more you know
and
uh suspected expected to
have a story for every single one of
them and
uh
you know you try not to get cynical
about you try not to get burned out
about it and so basically most of your
head is spent trying to like fine-tune
your process and trying to do this right
and um
yeah you gotta sort of figure out when
activists are telling you the truth when
the police are telling you the truth you
know that's much more important you have
to figure out what activists actually
know things which ones don't right like
there's a lot of wild goose chase type
of stuff where
someone will promise that they can help
you
talk to axe person right but that person
is not really like doesn't actually know
um
and so yeah you gotta you just like
slowly learn the how these things are
very similar in different cities and
then and then it starts to feel a bit
repetitive right like you um
you go and then you're trying to make
sense of this tragedy
and then at the same time you know
you're just thinking wow this is just
like
this is just like charlotte you know
like this is just like
baton rouge and uh
i don't know it both reinforces
the violence that's happening
uh and uh
and also just how many these communities
are getting traumatized by this violence
[Music]
we all do it
we all
take number twos and then the question
is what happens after around the world
when you need to wipe you actually don't
wipe you use water you use something
called a bidet here in the u.s we're a
little bit behind the curve on a number
of things and one of them is the way we
take care of the basics if you order
tushy
it's like a bidet that connects to your
everyday household toilet it's cleaner
it's better for the environment it's
more effective it's modern it's european
it's asian it's sustainable it really is
like an upgrade
it's one reason why i'm very happy to be
sponsored by tushy give the gift of
cleanliness to yourself your loved ones
this holiday season and get 10 percent
off plus free shipping right now at
hellotushi.comyang you can tag them at
hellotushi on social media so they can
help celebrate that's
hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off and free shipping
cleaner more environmentally friendly
no you can't go wrong
your book had a lot of things that i'd
never seen before
and
one of it one of the things you wrote up
about attending these protests is you
talked about how
uh
you didn't like a lot of activists
because it seemed like they were forced
into roles and and it kind of made them
seem
a bit like performers
to you which was fascinating to me and
that there's like a speaking circuit
that follows and then some people get
absorbed into the speaking circuit but
then others don't and then the ones that
don't get absorbed uh feel kind of left
out and embittered uh and then the ones
that do uh continue to make a living
essentially because it there's
there is like an ecosystem uh to
activism and recently there was this
brouhaha you probably saw where there
was going to be a reality tv show called
the activist and then people just
shouted it down yeah what was that about
yeah
that seemed like the worst idea
it clearly seemed like the worst idea of
all time so those are people who don't
know what i'm talking about there was a
reality tv show where there's going to
be an activism competition
uh and whoever one got to like go to
davos or something or like present it
right it was literally they went to
davos i think yeah yeah but but yours
was the first account where it actually
talked about how
various activists
uh would would try to
uh make the case in different ways and
show up the protests and then some of
them wound up being professionalized and
others didn't yeah it's interesting i
mean i want to make a distinction here
which is that the reason why i kept
going these protests wasn't because it
was just my job i mean i could have
asked to be on a different beat you know
or i could have just not done this job
the reason i went was because i've
always been very moved by the thought of
people
walking out of their houses just normal
citizens walking out and engaging in in
an active unified descent you know i
think it's the most important thing that
americans can do
and you know i come i was born in korea
korea is a country that protests all the
time right it's like the one thing that
koreans do right i think that we're sort
of known more for other things at this
point but like you know the sort of the
unifying experience of people my parents
age for example in korea is that they
just went to a lot of protests and so
there's two sides of me that that sort
of appreciate this and um
but yeah there are like when trying to
decipher this like as a reporter the
people who are going to appoint
themselves the spokespeople are
sometimes not the people who have just
walked out of their houses right who
have sort of been fed up you know this
is like the fifth time
sixth time tenth time they've seen
someone shot by the police in in this
neighborhood over the years and they're
they're just fed up right like i think
those people
um some of those people do end up being
leaders right some of those people do
end up taking leadership roles and i
think that like when that happens
generally that it's fine but there also
is a sort of professional class of
activists and i not i don't i think that
say that i don't like them as a little
bit too strong but it's difficult to
interview them sometimes right because
they just have talking points and they
sort of blow through them
and in the end you don't have anything
that's particularly
relevant to the story at hand right it
is it is just a lot of sort of
uh stuff that almost feels abstract when
you talk to the when you talk to them
and so um
yeah i wouldn't say that that it's a
dislike of those people i think some of
those people do end up doing good things
but certainly the the class of activists
that you were talking about right like
the the sort of professionalized media
savvy ones
uh are
are present and honestly at the
beginning of my career when i first
started
uh reporting on this like i wasn't
really like i i made some mistakes where
i wasn't really thoughtful about that
you know where um
where maybe i like talked to some people
who i thought were
who ended up you know sort of being in
that
type of class but at the same time i
think about it now and i just like well
but when i met them they weren't you
know and so it's it's a process that
sort of happens and you know some people
think that they can do more good if they
have a bigger platform and then some
people stay rooted in the community and
sometimes that's great and we all want
you know like i think that's the option
that people would instinctively say is
better but at the same time you know
like it's it's important to have a big
platform and say some things too so i i
don't i feel somewhat ambivalent about
it right like i just think but i don't
think that the i don't think that the
phenomenon that you're describing is is
not true it's really tough jay because i
you know i i've been a public figure
i've been
uh somewhere trying to make things
happen and when i was running my
nonprofit that i'd founded
the organization demanded that i go to
conferences where people had money and i
get in a panel and i try and you know be
in front of everyone and talk up the
mission and whatnot uh and it it seemed
like the resources were pulling me in
one direction and then the work however
you define it was pulling me in the
other direction
um but i'm a goal-oriented uh math guy
and so i was like all right let's go get
the resources like the best thing i can
do
and so like i feel really bad for folks
because that that's the tug of war that
they get pulled in
oftentimes uh you know all these kind of
glitzy seeming opportunities come up
you're like oh if i go there then i'll
be around people who can really help
move my organization forward and then
you go there and i gotta say it is the
worst feeling because the the rich
people there it's not like they run
around just like doling out checks to
folks
right they make they make you they make
you dance a little bit right yeah
there's this whole kabuki elementary and
they're just like oh you know really
impressed with your work let's get
together call my people and then you
like call their people and sometimes
they have an officer you know it's like
it is like this
entire uh ecosystem really a marketplace
i mean that's one of the problems in
american life is that at this point
there is a marketplace for
activism and you know that's why one
reason why that reality tv show cracked
me up so much i mean you know then
people found it like super objectionable
yeah
it did seem to be rooted in some sort of
id you know where it's like okay why
don't we just go full bore here
it was it was dark like i mean maybe
something but but i've been very dark
you know in some ways myself i mean as a
non-profit leader you're you're in some
ways a professional activist um so this
book makes a lot of very very big
arguments and points
it does in such an unflinching way that
i've never seen before
what drove you to write this book what
was the process
you'd written a novel before that
hammered away at some of the same themes
but this is a book of nonfiction
um
yeah like what was your did you have
like a clear vision uh or
uh
mission and what was the process like
putting this book together because you
know it's a real it's a really
impressive piece of work it must have
taken you quite some time
yeah it took me about four to five years
to write um
you know i took a couple breaks in there
but yeah i think it was it was a long
time longer than i expected um
i you know like i have been writing
about asian issues for about a decade
right or like uh
and you know like you said it started
with sports right it searched jeremy lin
uh the first piece i think i ever
published anywhere i published for free
and it was about jeremy lin when he was
at harvard and like the rapper
jyn the mc do you remember that guy from
freestyle from of course mcg man i'm
friends with it and i actually went and
saw
do you know mcginn did uh yang for new
york rap you must have seen that [ __ ]
right now that's right oh yeah yeah i
remember and he did a bunch of
presidential stuff for me too so anyone
can google uh andrew yang mcginn all
this stuff comes up but i was hip to
jeremy lin when he was still in college
at harvard i went and saw a college game
with his so that that just goes to show
did you did you watch the freestyle
friday stuff when it happened with no no
i just heard you know that the chinese
rapper came and you know went undefeated
and got a good deal and all the rest of
it and you know his first song came out
was i think speak chinese
it's fake chinese yeah yeah yeah like y
clef produced it um
yeah i so i had started there and i i
didn't really know what i was going to
do as a writer and honestly like at the
time i wasn't particularly interested in
writing about identity or anything like
that like well i just want to intercede
man
a book about identity from someone who
didn't want to write about identity
which is one reason why i really enjoyed
it but continued
yeah well i knew and uh so i had a
couple ideas when i started writing it
the first was that i had been writing
about this
population and don't been doing a lot of
uh reporting in immigrant neighborhoods
at the time right and so i realized that
there was this big disconnect between
the way that people like me right or
even you right like who are you and i
have a lot of common background children
sure man let me in for sure right right
so like sort of first uh people who were
raised in the united states uh sort of
in
places that were mostly white or were
mostly white and black right in my case
um
and that sort of had to form this
identity almost by themselves like in
isolation
and that you know one of the things that
you learn is that you learn how to sort
of deal with rich white people right you
learn how to talk their talk you learn
how to sort of ingratiate yourself into
their circles and those people end up
being and then you end up going to an
elite school and then you sort of
graduate and then you become one of the
people who is able to sort of occupy a
position of messaging and power within
that community now the reality of it is
that you may have absolutely no
connection with that community at all
but just because you look like them you
become their spokespeople right and so
um
while reporting in all these immigrant
communities and also you know all my
cousins sort of grew up in these
enclaves too so i was very close with
them i always knew what they were hip to
so
in the end i was just like there's such
a big disconnect between these two right
like the mainstream asian american
narrative has nothing to do with the
vast majority of asian americans in this
country right and that
the vast majority of asian americans in
this country don't even know what the
term asian american means right like and
that includes people like my parents
like i don't think my parents have ever
used the term asian american they refer
to themselves as korean sometimes they
refer to themselves as american
i don't think they've ever said they're
korean-american
and nor and asian-american is some
just weird concept to them right so
um and my parents are pretty assimilated
right like they're not they're not
people who uh you know they speak
english they they understand the concept
of asian american but um it's not
something that's real to them and so
it's an interesting book in that it is a
book that i think argues
quite forcefully i hope against like
this type of like uh kind of i don't
know how to put it but like progressive
identity politics right like where i
think like none of it is really true
um at the same time while trying to
understand what asian-ness means right
like what does it mean because it
certainly is a category right like you
and i are both asian um no one would
deny that neither of us would deny it
but i don't know a lot of times i think
that like you and i i would imagine from
you know this the first time we've
spoken but i certainly have followed
your career we know some people in
common it's just like you know i feel
very ambivalent about the about the
identity i i i assume you do too
well
you put it in such simple terms that uh
i think most people can understand and
this is the quote is
we know we don't have it as bad as you
uh i.e black people but we also aren't
white
and we need a way to talk about it
yeah
right right that's the that's sort of
the realization i think a lot of asian
people come to usually in college right
i think that's when it sort of happens
for a lot of people but um
or maybe in your early 20s if you don't
go to college but you sort of have this
understanding that like you're trying to
place yourself in the black white binary
in america right and
um i don't think many asian people like
actually want to become white you know
where they're like oh i wish i had
blonde hair and blue eyes and stuff
um
and so you're just like okay i'm not
white you know and uh but like i i don't
i understand that my life in a lot of
ways is easier than it would be for
if i was black and so i think that's
sort of the contradiction or the you
know like sort of the two polls that
people fight against their you know
their whole lives really yeah you talk
about how
uh america has a black white binary race
construction which i think a lot of
people recognize
and that uh asian americans get torn
between either associating with white
liberals uh
or
as black people uh and the oppressed
minority um but aren't really accepted
by either group truly
uh and that's the premise for the title
of your book the loneliest americans is
like look we don't belong in either camp
uh and trying to belong in either camp
is kind of a fail
[Laughter]
so yeah yeah that's the general idea and
you know like one of the things that
my own life was basically spent uh
because i grew up mostly in north
carolina and north carolina has a lot of
white people it has a lot of black
people right and so uh my childhood was
spent with a lot of white kids a lot of
black kids and
um
for most of my childhood i identified
much more with black kids uh at schools
that i went to
to the point where like when i was i saw
a photo of you when you were in high
school right like with the
with the long hair and everything like
that right like so i had a version of
that where i was wearing like
timberlands and you know like wearing
like mark echo hoodies and just only
listening to rap right and so
and i still think there's part of me
that that is grounded in that type of
identification
but when you think about it right like
it was like uh
you know like it was an isolated
identification right i had friends who
were black but i wasn't
like it wasn't like i had fully
inhabited that or knew of the culture
very well you know i was doing the type
of thing that young people often do it's
just type of appropriation oh jay i just
want to
interject because like what happened
with me growing up in a predominantly
white area with very few black people or
asian people
but if you're a
a boy
uh you just want to be respected as
like a male
and i think that black culture and
hip-hop
um was the exemplar of essentially
non-white masculinity and so if you're
an asian kid like one way you could be
kind of masculine is to be hard and
listen to a rap and hip-hop and you know
like uh wear the gear and stuff like
that at least that was my
uh
interpretation of it where i also
listened to a lot of rap and hip-hop and
the rest of it because you know i i just
wanted to be tough like i felt like my
masculinity was always in question
what would you listen to well you know
i'm a little bit older so this is like
when public enemy first came out and
stuff like that uh then right right you
know iced tea right
so it was that but i also listened to um
uh like grunge and alternative and that
stuff because that that was you know
pretty dumb i guess it was the 90s so
those were like the two major
uh strains it was
like the
tupac biggie hip-hop strain and then
there was like the nirvana pearl jam
um and you saw my high school photos you
saw that you know i definitely listened
to some grunge
the alternative thing yeah but but i had
a lot of anger
uh and so you know the anger
if you were non-white and you wanted to
be tough like it it meant uh essentially
in my mind blackness at the time because
there was certainly no
depiction of like asian-american
masculinity
to be had right right right it's
interesting kids now have it i guess
right but in a way that feels so foreign
to me i want you know does it feel
foreign to you like i guess i i
sometimes think about it and i see like
uh
you know i see these tick tocks and it's
like these like white kids in indiana
and they're trying to learn how to speak
korean because they're in love with like
a bts member you know and i was just
like what is that like you know what
would have been like for me in high
school if like a bunch of
white kids are trying to learn how to
speak korean and we're like you know be
like oh my god are you korean that's so
cool you know so i think that for kids
today it's like uh it might be a little
bit different but for me it was like
it's just like mind-blowing to even
think about that
why would you learn how to speak korean
i'll tell you about one of the the
funnest
times on the presidential trail and this
is fine it's a day off for me i was back
in new york city's day off i was with my
wife and her cousin
and then he just looks up and randomly
and says rich brian is in town he's uh
doing a concert you know rich bryan the
the rapper
right yeah
yeah and so i was like oh i'm friendly
with him on twitter
um and then he was like do you want to
try and go by the concert and i was like
sure so then like i ping rich and i'm
just like hey uh you know i'm in town
uh he's like yeah come on by so i end up
going to the concert with my wife and uh
her cousin and my brother-in-law and we
go backstage
and then we arrange it with rich brian
where i was going to go on stage like a
surprise and just like announce myself
and you know just shoot the [ __ ] and i
got so
nervous because i'm like do they know
what the [ __ ] i am
what's going on and so
um so i was backstage and i came out and
then happily the crowd was really
excited to see me and like you know the
the rest of it um but there it was
really awesome to see frankly like you
know an asian rapper
like in this case like thousands of uh
hip-hop fans who were there who were
almost exclusively asian i'd say
and whatnot but of course none of that
stuff existed when you and i are growing
up
yeah none of it i mean i guess like uh
you know um
it was hard and so yeah you don't you
didn't really have that so yeah i agree
with you i think that it was a bit of
the
idea of trying to find some form of
masculinity that made sense right where
you just don't want to be thought of as
a dork right
um and that was basically it yes that
was really the the thing to avoid it's
like don't don't be the asian nerd so
anything to avoid that any
thing you could latch on to so in my
case one of the things too i felt
pressure around was sports did that
happen to you in north carolina
uh
until middle school or so i was pretty
good at sports and then
it i hit some sort of cliff where i was
suddenly very bad i was no longer good
at them and so i think that during my
formative years i played a lot of sports
and i do think that that helped quite a
bit right and then by the time i was in
ninth grade or something like that it
wouldn't have mattered so much and then
i just became like a kind of like stoner
guy on the um you know on the debate
team
i don't i don't even know what it was
but it was just like that was sort of my
thing you know um and
uh
who listened to a lot of rap um and that
was basically it but yeah i do think
there are some you know it's interesting
because there's like these two there's
like there weren't that many asian kids
at my high school right like maybe five
in my grade and two of them were super
jocks like one of them ended up playing
soccer at carolina you know like
starting when he was a fresh so he was
like one of the best high school soccer
players in the country and uh he was
like this five foot six japanese guy and
then there was my friend allen who lived
down the street from me who was like you
know more sort of nerdy and and sort of
your stereotypical nerd guy and so yeah
it was uh
you know you you always kind of look
around when you're in those situations
you're like what's the other asian
dude's doing right and it's like also
this form of betrayal that you feel
terrible about when you're doing it you
know because you're just like why do i
have to do this why am i doing this what
if i just didn't do this but then it's
hard to stop doing that right and so
that yeah i think uh i don't know
uh i've had to ask you this actually
like do you think that like i mean like
you and i are similar in the same age
grew up in similar situations i think
that we have similar sort of past right
uh
do you think like
you have kids like do you think your
kids are gonna like i i i almost feel
like my kid is not gonna
it's like growing up in different
different almost at least
for me right like
i so i look at the way my kids are
growing up uh and it's totally night and
day to the way i grew up my brother grew
up because my my parents came in they
were immigrants they didn't know
anything and so you know we just like
kind of showed up clueless
uh to the extent that we knew about
ourselves as asians it was like just
getting picked on and bullied all the
time by various kids and then
you know like just feeling like your
place in the country is always being
questioned
uh your masculinity is always being
questioned my kids don't seem to get any
of that like you know they're just
coming up there uh i i joke and just
talk about how soft my kids are my kids
are so soft
and i know you have a girl so in your
case you know maybe it's a slightly
different um
like uh
calculation
but i have a joke because when i was
running for president i talk about how
we're automating away the jobs and it's
making us insane and the rest of it and
so i'd show a picture of my kids and be
like my kids are way too soft to survive
the mad max apocalypse that's coming we
got to keep our [ __ ] together
for their sake and like there's a
picture of my boys that they just do
look really really
uh very sheltered um so uh it sometimes
upsets me jay but then i'm just like
yeah you know it's a different
generation it's a different time
uh you know like
they're just uh you know comparing their
childhood to mine it really is very
different my wife and i have a joke but
from before where we would pretend to be
uh
laundromat owners who didn't speak
english or whatever and then and then
just like you know or like have half of
it raised or else then like pop out with
their 18 and be like hey guess what
it turns out yeah
yeah yeah no i think about it too
because it's just like
you think like all right you know i went
through all this stuff and man i was
really you know it sort of it was
horrible but that's why i'm so tough
today you know and then i think and then
i just like so is what i'm saying is
that i hope that my daughter goes
through like long periods of racist
bullying you know it's like of course
not you know but you do have i think
that's like the thing between people
like us who went through that
position and now
have children who are probably not going
to go through that just because the
country is different or the
circumstances in which we raise our
families are different you know because
you know like my kids are growing up in
manhattan and going um to schools and
like that's a different vibe than
you know the upstate new york um school
i grew up in uh and the rest of it it is
a different time but you know we end up
in these enclaves too in our own way uh
you know because our circumstances are
different than our parents and we do
different kinds of work
[Music]
[Music]
people think i'm a very very upbeat guy
which i appreciate a great deal but we
all struggle we all get down in the
dumps and when you are down and facing
some issues that you want to talk to
someone about the fact is your friends
and family don't really want to hear
about your stuff
they'll hear about it once
and then after that i'll be like oh you
know
get someone else which
is why better help is so important
better help is on-demand professional
therapy whenever you need it you reach
out it's totally confidential and
professional and affordable we swear by
our sponsor better help carry it forward
because
it actually looks up to its name it's
better help than your friends and family
because they actually
want to help you and listen to what
you're going through
i want you we all want to start living a
better happier life as a listener you'll
get 10 off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
you can do it again that's better help
help dot com slash yang you'll be glad
you did and your loved ones will be glad
too
[Music]
i loved the book because i felt like you
just cut to the core of a lot of things
around identity and there's like this
predominant racial set of narratives
that you kind of questioned or poked
holes in
and i thought the the maybe like the
biggest example of that is when you
talked about
the
uh the treatment of the beatings of
asian elders during covid
uh and and how
uh there were some
uh narratives that
the press just completely would not
touch
um and then you put them in these terms
and i'm gonna read at least one of them
it says
white liberals talk about ending racism
but they don't mean us
in fact they will actually deny us
justice to protect black assailants with
the observation that a
significant number maybe even uh
preponderance of the attacks on asian
elders were by
african americans in oakland and new
york city and other things
and then you write if the rules were
reversed and asian men were randomly
attacking and even killing old black
people there would be nationwide
protests i had never seen that put in
those terms
uh and i i frankly am grateful that you
did it or that someone did it
because
there was such like a disconnect where
uh if
there was an issue of
um
violence against asians
there there was a lack of coverage or
discussion about
um like the the nature of the
uh or the identity of some of the people
that were doing the attacking
yeah i mean i i would say like you know
in that section i was trying to
encapsulate what a lot of the thoughts
of
asian people at the time were right and
so i'm not necessarily speaking as
myself there right but i'm trying to say
this is what people were thinking right
like like these are the thoughts that
peop that people especially in immigrant
enclaves like right people who are
recent immigrants right like when they
try and understand the racial calculus
in this country this is just something
that they come up across right like they
see these videos and they go and they
say okay well it seems like uh you know
the last three videos have been black
assailants right and um
like where's the outrage right and then
they think about like what they what
they went uh sort of the
the the summer before right and they
think about the protests around george
floyd and they just think
why are these two things not equal right
like why why why does a country not care
about us
in the same sort of way and like what
are where what are our leaders our
supposed leaders saying right now i
don't think that necessarily these are
productive thoughts to have in fact i
would say many of them are unproductive
right they're not contextualized in
american history in some ways uh and i
also think that like uh you know there
is some
there is like a danger in expressing
them publicly right like i think that
like it it can be destructive right like
it's not something that everyone doesn't
need to sort of be this gigantic truth
teller the truth is going to end up
causing a lot of division
but
now were people having those thoughts
though oh absolutely you know of course
they were having those thoughts because
that's just the human sort of nature in
terms of like well why aren't things
fair for me why am i not getting the
same sort of treatment and yeah i think
that that was a very predominant thought
at the time right and i think it's still
a predominant thought i think it affects
politics right and i think it affects
the way in which people think about the
democratic party and progresses and in
particular right like they think well
you know these are supposed to be the
anti-racist people you know like why are
they not protecting us and you start to
see messaging in asian communities you
start to see messaging online that is
essentially just saying like hey you
know these people don't actually have
our backs right like they're trying to
they're trying to take away our test
schools right they're trying to keep us
out of harvard uh they don't care when
we're getting beat up in the streets
because they don't want to criticize
other minorities you know that like
and like i don't know
that is a very powerful message right
it's a powerful message because i think
that uh
that it has enough it sort of goes right
into the sort of lizard brain of a lot
of asian people right where they're
having these thoughts that they don't
want to admit that they're having and it
says like it's okay to have these
thoughts this is the truth
and like i think that from that you can
create like a very powerful reactionary
type of
politics that frankly terrifies me you
know like i don't think that we should
base our uh
politics on grievances and anger right
but i i i just see it happening right
now and um you know you can see it in
the polls after virginia you can see it
in the polls in
in new york uh
you know you can see it almost
everywhere right now that there's some
swing coming well i'm certainly with you
like i also want to get away from people
uh
grinding axes
or having these grievances and division
uh you know i certainly i hate trying to
blame
um
large groups of people for like a
particular action especially along the
lines of race you know it's like
like if someone does something it's like
that that's not like all people of that
race
you know it's like
uh and uh in terms of this the the
violence against asian elders like i
made the case look half of this is being
perpetrated documented by people who are
struggling with mental illness so let's
focus on getting people more services uh
that's something that we should all be
able to get behind um i i found myself
frustrated that we were all trying to
make it seem like
if we had like social media campaigns
saying you know asians are people and
like racism is bad like that'll do the
trick and i was like
like this is
you know like it's not like someone's
gonna see that campaign and be like oh
like that now you know like now my
desire to be an asian grandma it's gone
you know it's like it's just someone who
is really really uh in a very bad way
themselves and then and they're unable
to
check what's like a nasty dangerous
sometimes even
violent impulse
um so i i'm with you on trying to to go
another direction and i think that one
of the goals to try and get there would
be
just being able to accept a degree of
complexity it's like you have these
press driven narratives that are always
uh to your your major point just so
binary in nature it's just like this is
the narrative we're going with and then
anything that that doesn't fit that
narrative we're going to this kind of
hand wave away
but if it's in that narrative then we're
just going to go full bore oh yeah yeah
i mean that's like you know like that's
basically just been the crisis of uh
my intellectual life for the past two
years is just like just frustration with
that type of thinking right which is
just that if it doesn't if you if it's
not one way then you must be on the
other side right and so like when you're
assessing the attacks on on old asian
people right like uh there was at the
beginning there's this thing there's
like these are about white supremacy
right like this is all white supremacy
and she's like i don't know if that
makes sense to me you know
it certainly doesn't make sense to the
people who are being attacked and in
those communities like if you told them
they're like what's white supremacy have
to do with this also like maybe they
would even say what's white supremacy
right like these are immigrant
communities and um
and they're experiencing it in a very
different way and so then if you try and
describe the way through reporting and
talking to these people like the way
that they are feeling right and saying
that look this is a complex thing you
know some of it might make you very
uncomfortable you might dislike a lot of
these people and think that they're
racist oh that's fine right but we
shouldn't describe it with the
as it's something it's not just because
it makes you know a certain type of
liberal person comfortable right because
that's all that is right in the end it's
like it's a lot of sort of elite asians
sort of getting together and just being
like what's the most comfortable way
that we can describe this like oh the
most comfortable way that we can
describe this and still keep our sort of
progressive bona fides is to say it's
about white supremacy do hashtag
campaigns right talk about like the
times we were bullied as children et
cetera et cetera et cetera and to try
and make it about us right instead of
the the sort of like
unsavory asians right that we don't want
to talk about right in a way it's like
this is it's an act of mass erasure
right because like and it even erases
the victims themselves and
i found that extremely frustrating
throughout that time and so that's why i
wrote that chapter i was just trying to
be i i'm not saying that like we have to
think of that we we should start a race
war or that's not the opposite of
right and just saying like we gotta just
be honest about this you know like we
gotta and we and we should listen to th
not we don't have to do the things that
they say but we should at least like
accurately assess what they say you know
like and then you have this sort of
narrative that it's like a bunch of
people
uh being like oh we're all doctors and
so why would you attack us you know just
like we're not all doctors you know like
like also what does that have to do with
anything so like yeah i don't know
there's a
class and there's like an immigration
status element to it that uh
that i think is never talked about and
so i hope that the book would sort of
jab a finger at that
[Music]
yeah i think that's one of the primary
messages of the book is that you
describe uh children of the immigration
act of 1965 which is definitely me and
you
people whose highly educated parents
were let in when when that was the
preference
uh and then you have the more recent
immigrants who don't think of themselves
as asian-american maybe often aren't
engaged politically they might not speak
english very well
and there's a concern of the former
group that's around cultural issues
representation in media
uh
politics
and the attempted
creation of an asian-american political
identity
and then there's the lived experience of
the vast majority of people who don't
have those experiences or advantages or
that sense of collective identity people
are more like your parents maybe they'd
identify themselves as koreans in
america or cambodians in america or
whatever the group happens to be
and that your
recommendation is that uh asian
americans in the former group the
educated group should be
taking on
the true
issues that are facing
uh the latter group which uh which have
been suffering in many ways especially
over the last number of months like that
your recommendation is to make common
cause with
uh with that group which by the way is
probably larger is that fair to say
yeah yeah i mean the example that i give
in the book and the one that i speak
about quite a bit is that like after the
georgia spa massacres right which is
this you know traumatic experience i
think of extremely traumatic experience
for a lot of asian americans uh it was
about a day of people talking about the
actual tragedy and then in the
mainstream media and in all the
messaging channels like the conversation
abruptly shifts right it becomes a lot
of people like you and me right who sort
of grew up with educated parents and had
went to good schools and now occupy
these sort of elite
places talking about ourselves right and
what do we talk about we talk about like
microaggressions in the corporate
workplace right we talk about uh the
time when our i certainly do not try and
talk about those but continue
you did it you didn't i said people
people who grew up like us right
um who occupy these positions and so and
then i was thinking about it at the time
and i was like well why is this
happening you know these these people
are dead right these people uh are
you know they're involved in sex work
which i'm not saying anything bad about
sex but it's a precarious life right
it's one that needs protection right um
they are all recent immigrants like
they're not people who are born here in
the united states there are people who
are living in almost in extremely
economically precarious conditions right
they're not people who like are worried
about the the way in which they're
treated at a diversity seminar for
example at google or something like that
and yet these are the narratives that
proliferate everywhere right like the
sort of upper middle class like uh asian
spokesperson asian american spokespeople
start to take over and it becomes about
them
and
i think that that is like a i think that
is a i think that's a path to nowhere
you know i think that it leads to zero
solidarity with other groups right like
i think that uh that it makes it so that
other groups think that like our
arc that that all asians have no
problems except for
what role scarlett johansson stole from
one of us you know he's like who wants
to be in solidarity with a group like
that right like if those are the
expressed concerns and so the book is
more about like or the argument that
you're talking about in the book is just
that like look we need to like
we need to start thinking about people
who are actually less fortunate you know
we have to think about these immigrant
communities we have to think about
the people like people in georgia who we
say we care so much about but also are
erasing from this narrative almost
immediately and replacing with us right
and so
um i think that's a very difficult thing
to do but i don't really see any other
pathway for like whatever this thing
that we call asian american identity oh
i'm going to suggest another pathway uh
you might not like it but i'm just going
to throw this out there
so in a way it's like ronnie chang's
recommendation where he talked about how
we're going to be the referee
[Laughter]
so you have a country that's coming
apart and i'm going to propose that
asian americans become the glue that we
become the unifying group that's trying
to solve the real problems keep everyone
together uh and when you talk about who
we fight for i i mean i love the idea of
trying to
uh
elevate and embrace the cause of recent
immigrant uh workers and part you know
because i mean that they remind me of my
family and everyone i'm sure like a lot
of people
feel the same way
but i want us to try to make the country
whole to see like america's interests as
ours
and say to folks too that if the reverse
is true if this country disintegrates
which by the way it's on track to do uh
it's gonna be terrible for everyone it's
gonna be terrible for us
that's that's my case i don't know what
you think
i think that it's i think that there's a
lot of asian people who fill that role
right and it's like something that i
think like
it's something that wesley yang writes
about too right where he talks about how
like you know like the asian male is
sort of like the every male right
because like he doesn't really find any
identification with any sort of culture
and so he just becomes sort of the
default right like i think that that
there is some in that but i also just
think that like i don't know can you
really like what do you think these
immigrant populations are gonna get
right like i guess i'm just having a
hard time uh picturing like how they
would be mobilized in that sort of way
right how they would see it in their
best interest well if you look at these
immigrant populations and you described
in your book about your parents it's
like these came in and just wanted to
make a living you know something that's
like wanted to like made a decent life
and i think that's what motivates a lot
of folks uh you know in in a big way to
me i i want to
create the conditions where that still
is true for people who show up and you
know they don't need to worry about
being asian and you know getting
um beaten up in some way uh it it's like
a functional america
uh it allows them to fulfill that
ambition
i suppose right right
yeah i guess i just think that that
um for me the political work is always
just going to be about
um
figuring out ways to have solidarity
with other groups right and uh
specifically like black and latino
groups right like in in america and i
think that for
a lot of asian americans who are you
know in my position for example where
they're they're okay financially and um
but they are always trying to think
about themselves how am i going to fit
within this progressive space right i
think those asian americans don't
necessarily care about what white people
think about them you know i don't really
care what white people think about me
i'm 41 years old you know i'm sort of
over that right i think that the thing
that
those asian americans think about quite
a bit though is what black people think
about them right like how because they
see
that as the only way to sort of have a
type of solidarity type of politics that
they can be proud of right and and that
i think that that's why there's so much
sort of like
care around some of these issues around
these attacks for example right like
people are really really upset about
saying something that they feel will be
treason us to that type of solidarity
now the contention i make in the book is
that that sort of solidarity is very
fraught right like that that outside of
places like the academy or outside of
places like i don't know corporate
boards or something like that or
diversity spaces like it's not it's it's
very difficult to say that it's there
you know if you're having a conversation
about in in the new york mayoral race a
new phrase was coined
which someone used people of color and
then someone said well like you know
yang's of color and they were like no no
people are more color
[Laughter]
right right and it seems like every day
a new term is created to sort of like
push asian people out of like this
coalition right and so i think that
mindsets is just like we need to just
kind of be honest about that right and
if our goal which i think should be our
goal like i mean this totally like this
is like the purpose of my life's work
basically it's like can we build
meaningful coalitions with those people
can we have meaningful solidarity with
like uh black and latino when you say
that you'd say i would say can we build
meaningful coalitions with
people with anyone like i take anyone
you know
right right sure but like but you know
for me for me it really is like a center
around like you know like what what
would be like a sort of politics of
dissent right like i'm much more to the
left than you politically right so um
and i would just say that you know you
need to start doing work that resembles
work that other people are doing right
and i think that there are a lot of
asian american activists who are doing
this type of work right now right
they're totally ignored right they're
they're sort of but they're doing work
that's like kind of like helping laundry
workers or helping bike messengers
whatever like um
delivery drivers
right right right and i mean i i think
that like early on like when you're in
your like 20s or something like that
you're pretty involved in this sort of
stuff weren't you um or like you're
involved in asian americans yeah yeah
yeah quite quite uh quite a lot
yeah so like i think that um
that if there i just think that that
would be a much more appealing
type of work for people to do would be
more satisfying but at the same time and
i think that it would have a lot of
overlaps with the type of work that like
you know coalitional black latino
activists are doing as well now it
doesn't mean that you have to have all
this be determined by activists right a
lot of this is just work in your daily
life and i think that's the only path
right but it's difficult it's difficult
like the end of the book is me just sort
of expressing my own
doubts that this will ever work right
like that because we're so incentivized
by capitalism yeah well i i the takeaway
i took was was you know you present a
couple of different choices and then
you're like well you know we kind of
need to forge our own identity in our
own path which is something i agree with
um
there are a couple of things i wanted to
make sure and cover there was one line
that just made me laugh out loud and i
want to share it just because i thought
it was so rough um you're talking about
this guy doug uh who makes his own pilot
in hollywood
uh um and
uh you you write about how people don't
really pick up on this story even the
asian americans that traditionally
complain about depictions and media and
then uh you know he does his homegrown
pilot they don't seem to care and then
you write something and said this doug
and i understand is a pathetic story but
most asian american stories are pathetic
and i just laughed out loud and my wife
was like what are you laughing at and
then i like had her had her read that uh
like what were you thinking when you
wrote that
oh man like you know
i mean you know this like
people don't really care about our
problems you know
[Laughter]
especially asian dudes you know and um a
lot of i've i've been asked a lot about
who this book was written for and it's
not something you think about when
you're writing a book you just think
well i gotta get to the next page and oh
i'm really enjoying writing this part
this is really interesting like you
don't have this like picture of who
you're writing for when you do it maybe
some people do but i certainly don't um
but i thought about it and i was like
you know i think a lot of it is written
for sort of
i was listening to this podcast and you
know one of the things that the people
said i thought was actually quite a
student and said well i think he this
book is for sort of not online asian
people right like people who don't
follow politics that care like people
like my sister my sister doesn't have
any social media right
she must be she must but it's also
written i think she must be
like what's wrong with my life oh yeah
no she she just goes she does a lot of
hiking and starts surfing and hangs out
with her kid yeah she doesn't she's
never triggered
[Laughter]
so that's one of them but i don't know i
think in a lot of ways written for like
uh you know like i i think it's just
written for people who feel like kind of
[ __ ] up by you know um feeling
rejected and and a lot of that is is
based on being like an asian dude i
think like you know you just sort of
feel like i don't know like nobody
really cares about our feelings i think
that asian women go through a different
version of that right but um
and so i'm not discounting that i just
think like i don't know it's like it's
kind of like there's no way to tell
these stories without people just sort
of laughing at us you know and so and be
like oh man you know like you're such a
loser i'm going to share a story that
this is what's going on in my household
because this might make you laugh
um so i i've i've run for a couple of
offices you know been through some
things uh i i my general attitude is
that
um no one gives a [ __ ] about you know
like
like what i'm going through
off to the side
uh and then
uh
i went over to a friend's house
and she bought my books very kind and
had me sign them uh you know
um and then among the books were some
books of poetry by andrew yang that i
did not write
uh there's apparently a guy named andrew
yang has like written like several books
of poems uh and some people
think it's me and the way it's
identified it's like you can't tell you
know anything about it so the guy's name
is andrew yang and it's all this like
bleak poetry about you know his
struggles and like you know like the
darkness and [ __ ] like that
um and my wife finds this hysterically
funny she like goes out and buys the
books of poems and is like i really want
you to read these aloud
um
but but there was a part of me that was
very uncomfortable which is like oh man
some people are going to like buy these
poems and think like i'm like writing
these poems
no i feel that yeah yeah because you
don't want to be there's a sort of mask
we put on right like where it's just i
don't know like stuff that like adrian
tomine writes about right or um it's
sort of like well
uh we can't really
like there's no sort of way to tell
these stories that is broadly
sympathetic that won't be that we know
that most people aren't cringing at you
know and so um
and i don't know that that's sort of
what i meant it's just like the asian
male story of struggle is very it's real
to me
[Laughter]
like we hurt you know
but then there's also this other thing
you know it's just like well it's tough
because nobody gives a [ __ ] and
everyone's gonna laugh at us
if we try to be hardest about it and so
i don't know i deal with it you know i
don't know self-medication and you know
general cynical affect or whatever but
you know it's it's a lot of like it's a
lot of like you know it's dealing with
this core thing and you know it's weird
to write a book when you're certain when
that's your conclusion about america
right which is like nobody really gives
a [ __ ] about anything i think right
while also sort of occupying a very high
position in the media right um
and uh then sometimes i think wow this
piece got a lot of traffic people really
do care what i think you know and then
they're just like no you know like it's
just
nobody gives a [ __ ] so yeah that's what
i meant by that line it's just like you
know our stories are kind of pathetic
well there were a lot of lines like that
in the book that just struck me as
unflinchingly honest uh i
appreciated your eye on a lot of complex
issues in a way that i thought really
cut to the heart of a lot of things i
shared a lot of it i mean you and i have
a lot in common
i think identifying the different
uh
sets of experiences of people who
you know might have access to certain
opportunities um
or or educational levels and whatnot and
then trying to lump us all together
um
is part of the problem really is that
like in america and you're a counter
example to this which is one reason i
appreciate you but um that it seems like
race is being try is being used as a
bludgeon in so many ways
you know it's like going around and
being like what's that you know you're
latino then you should be voting this
way what you voted that way then like
what the hell is wrong with you you know
it's like something's going on like
there
there is like this segmentation and this
division
uh and maybe the most important
contribution your book made was like
look we're human beings like there's no
monolith there's no asian american
identity that somehow like you know has
us all looking and thinking a certain
way
uh and so i i appreciated it
[Music]
you know when i was running for
president people would ask me about my
identity all the time and i just you
know part of it's like look i'm like i'm
a human being
you know it's like i certainly never lay
claim to representing like you know
millions of people's point of view
it's uh
did you feel that pressure like because
i you know i will say that i heard you
like uh
i had heard my friend had told me about
you but this was very early on and then
you did the sam harris broadcast and
then i listened to it you know and i was
like who is this guy you know like i was
and like part of me was like i've never
heard an asian guy like this in my life
like sort of like very upbeat and and
and uh you know like sort of just being
like these are my ideas without sort of
talking about identity at all right like
even though you're a guy who's running
for president is sort of like you know
you know i think you would admit like
you know not traditional path towards
becoming the president
admit that like what a revelation
and so i was i remember listening to it
i just feel like wow you know like i
just don't know any
asian people like this right like uh and
or anyone who would do this right like
that was the other thing that i was
thinking is like i don't know did you
feel like you had to clear away some of
that stuff because i that's that's why i
was surprised when you know i'd be
talking to some of our mutual friends or
something like that and they'd be like
you know like when andrew was uh in his
20s he was like really involved in a lot
of asian american space stuff you know
and he was doing a lot of stuff like i
don't know did you feel like you had to
separate yourself from that i don't mean
to interview you now but i you know i
was just curious about it no not at all
man it's good fun um so
uh i i tell a joke in asian american
circles uh which you will understand
i say the first time you heard about me
your first reaction was
please let him not be terrible
oh 100
when you your first debate that was all
i was thinking you know because i was
just like your first presidential debate
i was like please don't make him
embarrassing please don't make any
make embarrassment please that was the
only thing going through my head you're
right yeah you got it so i mean that's
the way we think i told my team as much
too i was like look like the asians will
come after i demonstrate that other
people are into it and then
uh so so when you ask about you know my
my approach i genuinely was driven by
these big ideas around uh
automation ai and technology universal
basic income and i saw it as my service
to society
uh maybe even humanity to say look like
we have to mainstream these ideas but a
lot of the stuff i learned along the way
jay is just how messed up our treatment
of a lot of these issues uh
is
because of race um and i'll share a
story with you that
uh you know i share every once in a
while so i was on a panel with a guy
named michael tubbs who is the mayor of
stockton california young black
inspirational figure friend now
but after the panel he leaned over to me
and said andrew you can say [ __ ] i could
never get away with because of a young
black mayor was walking around saying
give everyone a thousand bucks a month
like you know they would laugh me out of
the room
but if the if the magical asian man from
the future says it then everyone's like
oh i guess we should listen we should
hear this out
so so there was like this identity
element to
uh my campaign but it was not me
talking about my identity
in large part because that's not what i
was there to talk about
[Laughter]
you know
but but i'm
you know cognizant of the fact that you
couldn't separate out who i am from
the message of the campaign
yeah yeah yeah i think you're right i
think that they're i don't know i i've
thought a lot about the way that
people thought about you because you
know you were asian and i don't know if
i ever came to a very good conclusion
about it but i i think i agree with the
mayor from stockton right that it did
give you this sort of like futuristic
thing right like you did become
like you know this guy that you know it
sort of drops down just like here are
some cool ideas you know and
and you can do that in ways that he can
i think i think you're right yeah
well jay uh i just want to close on this
because i i just want to share this
experience as someone who's written a
book so you wrote a novel it's a very
personal experience and then when you
put it out of the world you do feel like
oh i hope people like it um and then
this is a non-fiction book that's at
least somewhat autobiographical so
there's a lot of personal investment too
you're like oh you know like as someone
who's written a few books now it's very
hard to just be like oh
like you know i don't care about
people's reaction to this book like you
do care
because you know you use that all this
time um so how how has the reception
been and what has your experience been
because i i know that there was at least
some
um some stuff that that uh you know i
saw in passing
yeah there's a group of uh not all not a
lot but there is a small group of asian
american studies professors who are very
proudly proclaiming that they're going
to refuse to read the book right and um
i didn't understand that i don't think
i'll ever understand that but you know i
will say that within our community that
there is quite a bit of gatekeeping
right and the reason why there's a lot
of gatekeeping is very sympathetic is
because you know like we said before
nobody really cares you know and so like
the market is so small that people feel
you know it's a crabs in a bucket type
of mentality people feel like they have
to crawl to the top right but we're all
killing each other and so i think that's
part of it i will say that the first
piece i ever wrote for zero dollars that
was published on my friend's blog in the
comments to that blog an asian american
studies professor showed up and was
lecturing me about all the things that i
wasn't referencing and all the people
that i didn't read you know all the
things that i didn't read and all the
things that i didn't cite right this has
been my entire career right that that uh
a group of of tenured professors
basically and and and and people who
have very you know think of themselves
as very very progressive people have
always had a bad reaction to me because
my general thesis has always just been
that asia united american identity
doesn't make sense to me it doesn't make
sense to most people it doesn't make
sense to most poor asians and that it is
really just sort of like uh you know
like it's a thing that mostly deals with
like elite people who go to elite
colleges and that you know that that
that is upsetting
um and so the bad you know they're those
people have you know somewhat big online
audiences and people always like fights
right and so that that sort of color the
first week of the book being out in a
way that was i don't know for a while i
thought it was funny you know but then
it it did make me mad because a lot of
the stuff that they were saying was
untrue right like so they were saying
that uh the book has that i've never
that i am not connected and don't report
on immigrant neighborhoods i have the
books about everybody because it doesn't
make any sense yeah
right also my entire career has been
like reporting about about immigrant
neighborhoods right uh about flushing
about uh you know like tibetan
populations in oakland like
places that that that people don't even
know have immigrant neighborhoods like
that that's been my career so it's just
a lie you know and it's such a lie that
i don't even know how to respond to it
just be like you're describing somebody
else
and then there was a claim that like i
hadn't engaged enough in asian american
scholarship which like if you just open
the or the an activism which if you just
open the book and you look at the table
of contents there's two chapters on
asian american activism you know they're
just like these
i didn't know how to respond to it
because uh it was just lies right and so
um
i don't know it's very unpleasant when
people lie about you on the internet and
try and ruin like a uh you know a book
launch for you but at the same time you
know like uh i do have some like sense
of like
perspective on it right this is a small
group of people
they've been uh you know this is not the
first time that that that this group has
tried to
you know really criticize me i knew they
were going to criticize me and and i
sort of expected it i just didn't expect
it to sort of
become such a
narrative there or for them to sort of
you know start saying things that aren't
true and i certainly did not expect a
bunch of academics to refuse to read a
book right publicly like that's the
weirdest part about it yeah that seems
kind of like kind of the opposite of
their profession it's like this book
you know i'm like we'll never enter my
brain it's like well you know i thought
your entire thing was
uh you know learning
all right and there's all these
accusations their general accusation was
that like i was i have such a huge
platform i'm sure you get this too you
know and it's like you are the only
asian person who's allowed to talk and
so you need to be better and it's like
it's not true you know like there's so
many asian writers right now there are a
lot of different voices i'm one person
you know do i have a large platform sure
you know so do a lot of other people and
and they write all the time like they
were basically making it seem like i was
the only asian writer to ever write in
the new york times which you know i
actually find quite offensive to all the
other all my colleagues who are asian
who work in the new york times so um
i don't know i i i don't i didn't really
i had a week where or a few days where i
was mad about it and then my mom called
me and i was sitting in the bathtub and
she was like you start you know
i pick up the phone and she starts
screaming in korean which is when i know
that she's like actually very mad at me
and she was like stop responding to
people on twitter you know you're gonna
go crazy
all in korean and then and then
after that i stopped and since then it's
been fine
i will say
99.9 of the response i've gotten from
the book has been from people
um who sent me heartfelt emails or
tweeted about it or
uh
sent me dms or you know even called me
people that i've known from a long time
and
it's all been you know it's been
not everyone agrees with everything in
the book right it's not a book that is
meant to have a lot of people agree with
everything
but uh those types of conversations have
been great and that's you know like
that's most of my experience with the
book honestly right like the stuff that
happens on twitter well deservedly so
jay i mean the things i'd say about the
book is it's honest
it's personal
uh it's edifying uh you know even from
the glimpses she got now my wife evelyn
wants to read it um so you deserve so
you deserve the praise you should be
really proud of it uh and anyone who
does something you know in my mind
like it is uh a plus
you know i mean it's like i don't think
that that's one of the problems of today
really so um hats off to you i'm really
excited for you i'm excited for more
people to pick up the loneliest
americans
uh which uh i found to be a phenomenal
read
uh fun too like i did laugh a number of
times uh it's just brutal man it was
just like brutally honest like uh maybe
someone will make a movie out of
something out of it
yeah yeah i oh thank you the odyssey
part is the
nicest compliment of you know i i was
trying to write a book that
i don't know i don't understand it's i
have a very
sort of
a relationship with writing where it's i
don't it doesn't really linger you know
for me like i get it out on the page and
it's out and so under those conditions i
feel like it's okay to be as honest as
possible because you're not like worried
about what people think about you
because you're you don't even think
about it and you know it's almost like
this sociopathic like
break right once it's out then you know
like it's in the world it's not really
about me anymore and so i tried to be as
honest as possible and um you know if
anyone i hope that people just take that
away from it that you know like i'm
trying my best they really should stuff
i had never seen in writing before
uh it was awesome uh and you know keep
doing it man like anything you produce
uh like you can count me in as a fan uh
because even if i don't agree with it
i'm gonna say like you know this is
a very very unflinching look at the
world so thank you
okay thank you
[Music]
you